we're Jason and Amanda we live in Waze
with Ohio it's about 45 minutes south of
Cleveland Ohio we just had a baby in
December and in place we've become
debt-free and we had that option I
decided to stay home with our little
girl we didn't really have a plan per se
or financial goals we were just kind of
living life I guess I would say we're
against debt in any way he had a lot of
student loan debt and we started credit
cards yeah I think what it was it was a
year we got married yeah and his mom
came to us she had taken FPU and she
came to us and said and took this really
great class about finances and I would
really like for you guys to take it and
I'd be willing to pay for it I wouldn't
say we were excited to go no we tried to
go with an open mind though yeah if she
was think for the class we wanted to
make sure that we were getting the
information and you know kind of taking
it in the material we wanted it to be
true but we were just kind of being
negative about it we were like that
might work for somebody else but I don't
know if it's gonna work for us and we
just kind of had those thoughts and then
we were like wait what do we have to
lose let's try it paying off our cars we
you know we had five-year loans in our
cars and we ended up paying them off I'd
saved like six months of peace that for
me was the turning point you know
like this worked this could really work
and so then we got intentionally at that
point once we saw it working that was
when the hope kicked in and we really
felt like we could could do this right
if we paid off our cars in six months
apiece
you know then what else could we do so
we got duck free in July of 2015 and we
had our quarter in December of 2015 and
I just went on maternity leave and I
didn't return to work which was awesome
because you know we struggled with
infertility for two and a half years we
went through tests and infertility
treatments and all those things by God's
will we got pregnant
very early on and infertility treatment
we know now looking back had we have not
been through FPU or found devar or any
of that we probably would have you know
taken out a loan of a home equity loan
or put it on the credit card or
something just everyone says God has a
plan right but that was just amazing
that it worked out that way and that we
were able to you know pay off the debt
and then allow me to be able to stay
home with her we didn't even know that
we were struggling with infertility we
had no idea that that would be in our
future
Wow you feel like you're making your
payments and everything is fine in your
quote-unquote normal
and when something does happen in your
life that's when it's that's when the
realization kicks in that oh wow you
know either I have to go further into
debt or or make this not an option for
me or you get out of debt and you've
been able to pay cash for it we paid off
a hundred and forty-one thousand dollars
in three and a half years that journey
was was so emotional and so great but we
had so many things happen throughout
that journey and now we are able to do
you know anything that we want to do
basically because we have no debt other
than our house so we can start saving
for our daughters College our retirement
and we can start you know the awesome
goal of paying off our house early
[Music]
[Music]